en la mezquita más grande del país con
la mayor cantidad de musulmanes las
oraciones significan el inicio del
ramadán es la segunda vez que el mes más
sagrado del islám se ve afectado por el
cob y 19 con una gran parte de las
mezquitas del mundo cerradas el año
pasado por las restricciones estos
fieles en indonesia están felices porque
esta vez han podido volver incluso
aunque las celebraciones están
restringidas
con esta oración continuamos pidiéndole
a la que el kobe 19 se vaya pronto para
que podamos volver a orar en
congregación en esta mezquita en los
años que vienen
la mayoría de los países musulmanes
empezarán su ayuno de un mes este martes
uno de los cinco pilares del islam
típicamente el ayuno se rompe al
atardecer cuando la gente se
congregarían para el iftar y para los
restos conjuntos pero con las
restricciones de kobe 19 que varían de
país a país es probable que este ramadán
sea muy diferente alrededor del mundo
musulmán o el aumento de casos en
pakistán ha hecho que las autoridades
sanitarias le pidan al gobierno que
cierre las mezquitas este mes luego de
que el año pasado las normas fueran
ampliamente burladas
estamos tratando de hacer lo mejor que
podamos para seguir los lineamientos del
gobierno y durante el ramadán todos los
fieles necesitan usar una máscara traer
su tapete de oración y mantener la
distancia en filas separadas
en arabia saudita están los templos más
sagrados del islam que normalmente
atraen a más de 2 millones de fieles
cada año
[Música]
pero los peregrinos del ramadán este año
se verán dramáticamente reducidos luego
de que el rey no anunciara que sólo la
gente inmunizada tendrá permiso para
visitar los sitios sagrados del país